Marielle joins us from New Jersey a
Marielle welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you so much for taking my call
so my husband and I are currently in
Financial Peace University we have
completed baby step one and we are
budgeting to pay for our debt with the
snowball method good however one of the
mistakes that we made was released a car
and the lease for their car ends in May
and so in May we need to have a new
solution for my husband's car we've
agreed that we're not going to lease
again we want to buy a car that's used
and all of this but we're not sure how
does that how do we prepare for that
while also considering our looking to
pay off the debt in baby step 2 gotcha
what's your household income I'm about a
hundred and eight thousand that's good
news okay and how much do you need for
him to buy a car we were guessing about
ten thousand okay and we have until May
mm-hmm and how much can you save a month
towards that if you don't do anything
extra on your debt snowball right now we
can probably do about a thousand dollars
each month out of a hundred and eight
wait right out of a hundred and eight
thousand you can only save $12,000 a
year oh sorry I'm here I was thinking a
month well I was thinking a month -
that's only 12 $1,000 a month is $12,000
a year out of 108 is pretty puny yeah no
I think well right now with what with
the debt that we have and with the
expect our mortgage and all of these
things I think it's probably it could be
a little bit more so we're just getting
this started and so I was being very
conservative with it saying it I mean
that's gonna help you're gonna have four
thousand dollars for your car in May
you're four months great right mm-hmm
so we need to probably save more than
two thousand more than a thousand more
like two thousand that's gonna give you
eight thousand so I wouldn't what I'm
saying is I would stop your debt
snowball pay minimum payments on
everything
still do a beans and rice rice and beans
lifestyle no eating out no vacationing
put the kids up for sale on the dog and
a cat up for sale everything's gone
we're out of here okay
hardcore money and then I think you can
save $2,000 a month you've stopped your
401 k's right yep good okay and you're
not getting tax refunds right I'm not
sure about that if you are you need to
adjust your w-2s but you got a tax
refund to calculate into this if you got
one coming okay so what I'm trying to
scrape together five to ten thousand
dollars buy him a car buy me and then
let's kick this thing into gear because
behind the way that's going to help you
got rid of a car payment yeah no exactly
and that's why I just wasn't sure how it
would play in addressing the debt that
we have and accumulating additional debt
but that means I don't think you're
gonna have you know you're either going
to borrow some money for another car
which I don't want you to do or you're
going to delay your debt snowball a
little bit here a couple of three months
while you pile up some cash to get ready
to do the car deal then we can move on
from there now of course any money we
can squeeze out this budget that we
haven't found yet or any extra income we
can find or anything else we've got to
sell that we can sell to cause this
whole process to accelerate that all
goes into the equation but the faster we
can get five six seven thousand bucks
eight thousand bucks for him to have a
car the faster we can start kicking this
debt snowball down the hill but until
then I'm with you you've got to get
ready because it's going to be either-or
you're not gonna be walking that's not
reasonable not making a hundred eight
thousand but I want you to I want you to
really tighten the screws down this
budget I'd love to see you do two
thousand a month and sell some stuff and
whatever else well extra work or
whatever and that that puts you in the
five to ten thousand dollar range on the
car by May when you turn the keys in on
the stupid fleece and there you go hey
thanks for the call